today we're going to teach you how to
make a really stunning french dessert a
croquembouche this showstopper can look
pretty intimidating but combine some
simple baking techniques with
ingredients most people already have in
their pantry so let's give it a whirl
[Music]
a krogan boosh is a tower of cream puffs
topped with caramel so let's break it
down a bit there are three main steps we
need to make a custard a pad of shoe and
a caramel the first step is making the
custard since that takes a while to
chill so first add the milk and vanilla
bean to a pot over medium high heat and
bring that to a boil we use two vanilla
beans with the seed scrape to really
infuse the milk you can use vanilla
extract but real vanilla beans offer a
much more intense flavor that's
absolutely worth splurging for once the
milk comes to a boil take the pot off
the heat and let it infuse for 15
minutes without touching it in the
meantime you're going to beat the egg
yolks and sugar together at medium speed
until they're fully incorporated this
may take a while so be patient and if
you don't have a hand mixer you can do
this by hand but get ready for a workout
the batter should look pale yellow and
fluffy like this next you're going to
add the cornstarch and mix until that's
fully incorporated at this point the
milk should be ready to go take out the
vanilla beans then mix a half cup of the
milk into the batter then you can add
the rest of the milk and keep mixing
until the batter is smooth now we're
going to go back in the heat full
disclosure this is going to take a
little bit of time and patience you're
going to keep whisking this over medium
heat stirring constantly for about 7 to
10 minutes until the custard begins to
thicken for the first few minutes it'll
feel like nothing is happening but once
it gets going it thickens up really
quickly you'll start to feel some
resistance as you're whisking and then
it should only take one to two more
minutes the important thing is to just
keep whisking this entire time if you
don't you'll end up with some clumpy
custard no one wants that it's gross
once your custard has thickened you're
going to add some butter this is
optional but the butter will make it
creamier and let's be honest we're
already indulging a bit with this recipe
to say the least once the butter's
melted mixed in we're going to strain
the custard into a bowl again this is
optional it's just a way to get really
smooth silky custard and here's the last
step for custard you want to cover this
with plastic wrap and press it down to
the surface you really want to be
thorough with this and make sure the
surface is completely covered or else
the film can form at the top you want to
refrigerate the custard for at least two
hours you can also make it a day ahead
while that's chilling let's move on to
our pata shoe this is a common pastry
dough used in a ton of recipes you can
use it for eclairs you can use it for
churros and of course you can use it for
cream puffs like we are in this recipe
so first you're gonna add butter water
sugar and salt to a pot let the butter
melt down and bring it to a boil over
medium high heat make sure you have
everything ready to go before starting
the step because it moves pretty quickly
from here once it begins to boil
immediately turn off the heat and add
the flour use a wooden spoon to quickly
incorporate it until all the liquid is
absorbed and the dough begins to form a
ball at this point you can transfer this
to a stand mixer with a paddle
attachment which honestly will make your
life a lot easier but if you don't have
one you can also do this by hand you're
gonna start adding your eggs one at a
time making sure they're fully
incorporated before adding the next one
okay real talk be forewarned if you're
doing this by hand it's a workout pro
tip grab a friend and tag team this part
if you can the dough will become thicker
as you add more eggs when it's done it
should look thick and glossy and the
dough will start to pull away from the
edges of the pan like this once the
dough is ready it's time to fill up your
piping bag make sure you're using a
medium-sized standard round tip if you
don't have one you can always fill a
ziploc bag and cut off the tip when
preparing your piping bag make sure you
press the dough all the way down to get
rid of any air bubbles you also want to
twist the top pretty tightly and fold
any excess over the edge squeeze gently
from the top and use your other hand as
a guide as you pipe these into a
circular motion onto a parchment paper
lined baking sheet you want to start out
by piping a one inch circle then coming
up and in towards the center as you
circle around when you get to the center
stop adding pressure and pull up this
recipe will make about 150 cream puffs
so you're in for the long haul
but you'll get a ton of practice to
really get that perfect cream puff shape
dip your fingertip into water and gently
press down the tips to flatten them then
brush it with egg wash to get that
glossy sheen the crucial thing here is
to never open the oven door as they
start to bake if you do your cream puffs
might not puff once these have finished
baking and have cooled you can start to
fill them with custard take a wooden
skewer and gently poke the bottom of the
cream puff to make a small hole then
you're going to use a piping bag to
gently fill these with custard don't go
too crazy or your cream puff could
explode once the cream puff starts to
fill up and feel firm you're good to go
the last step before we assemble the
croquembouche is making a caramel
so you're gonna bring sugar corn syrup
and water to a boil over medium-high
heat once it begins to boil put the lid
on for five minutes once that's done you
can take off the lid and put in a candy
thermometer whenever you're making
caramel or candy thermometer is really
going to help you out you want to heat
the caramel until it develops a deep
amber color and reaches 300 degrees at
this point turn off the heat and add the
heavy cream and whisk the caramel will
immediately start to bubble up so you
want to be really careful at this point
so you don't get burnt the caramel will
lighten up in color and become smooth
and glossy now that our caramel is ready
we can start to assemble our
croquembouche you're going to have to
work pretty quickly at this point dip
the tops of the filled cream puffs into
the caramel and arrange them into a
large circle filling in the center as
you go to keep the top layers more
stable with each layer you're going to
come in a little bit and do the same
thing making smaller and smaller circles
until you've created a beautiful tower
once your tower is complete dip a fork
into the caramel and use that to drizzle
the caramel threads around the tower
this will create a caramel cage which
you see in a lot of classic
croquembouche recipes this step is
really easy to do and will make your
croquembouche look so amazing it's
absolutely worth doing voila you've made
a croquembouche this can be pretty time
consuming and look a little intimidating
but it's actually pretty simple when you
break it down plus now you know how to
make a custard a pad a shoe and a
caramel you know three elements that you
can use across a bunch of different
desserts best of all now you know how to
make this show stopping dessert
[Music]
i feel like if you bring a croquembouche
party like you fancy you fancy yeah if
someone showed up with a coca-boosh to a
party i'd be like you'd be like can i be
your friend oh really i'd be like
i would be like i want to be the person
that brings a crooked booster party can
i be your friend